this is sal i'm here with ben eater hi
sal and you made this this module i did
called the fundamental theorem of
arithmetic yes very exciting very
exciting this says that we can
essentially get to any any any whole
number greater than one right by by
taking products of prime numbers that's
right yeah that any number anything can
be made by by taking just the right
prime numbers by multiplying a bunch of
prime numbers together so and then right
over here we're essentially going to try
to do that and there's and there's one
and only one way to get to that number
there's only one way right right there's
not other yeah kind of ways only one set
of prime numbers that will get you to
any number oh very very interesting so
let's see so they say find the prime
factorization of 42. so when they're
saying prime factorization or when
you're saying since you wrote this
you're saying
factor this into all the numbers that
when i multiply them together i get to
42. well the prime numbers prime numbers
so we only give you prime numbers here
to work with you only give the prime
numbers 2 through 13. right it says use
arrows to change the exponent on each
prime number so the exponent is how many
times you're going to multiply that
that's right or and we have many videos
on this going into depth on exponents
but you could also one way to visualize
it how many times you're going to
multiply one times this number right yes
there's one
for at least this case right over here
we're multiplying one times two zero
times so you can absorb one there if you
multiply it by two once
you get a two there too and then if you
do it by two twice you get 2 times 2 is
4. so the prime factorization of 42. so
the way i i think well let's let's use
your hints okay sometimes i mean you've
got these hints we should think about if
they're so let's see i'd like a hint
sounds good i'd like a hint
so let's see what it tells us to do we
can fact we can use a factor tree to
break 42 into its prime factorization
which of the prime numbers divides into
42. so a good place to start is think of
any of those prime numbers and think
about which ones divided by maybe start
at the
the easiest one to think of this is an
even number two is going to divide into
it probably so so let's see if that's
what y'all confirm in the hints
oh yes right there 2 times 20 goes in
and we could do this on paper if we want
or we should sure but 2 goes into 42 21
times that's right and so i could just
try 2. i got 21 times all right but
we're not we're not done yet because 21
is not a prime number it's not even
listed here even if we were to keep
listing the prime numbers it's not it's
not 21 is not prime right and so and 2
does not go into 21 anymore no so we're
kind of done with the two
we have the twos so actually let's see
we're only gonna have one two right over
there right let's see three does go into
21. it does three does go into 21. and
so let's see so it should be three so 21
can be factored into three times seven
that's right so let's see if that's what
your hint can contribute
which are both prime yeah let's see if
that's what the hint confirms yes three
times seven three times seven and then
seven is prime and you're done that's
right so you can say so you're gonna
have uh you're gonna have this two right
over here you're gonna have a three and
then we're gonna need a seven two times
three times seven is four to do when and
we're done
and we go right over here answer check
the check click the to change your
answer no no i don't need to we already
did that i already did that so now i
just checked the answer and i'm done
correct next question and i got two and
we we encourage using some hints yeah so
we gotta we don't get the full get some
credit for that sure good about
ourselves okay let's do the next one
let's do the next one let's see what
shows up oh well we already know the
prime factorization of 21. we just did
that yeah yeah it's three we got a three
and we get a seven in there
oh there we go let's do another one
18.
so 2 goes into 18. it does 2 goes into
and so
and if i'm going to do this in my head
it's it's 2 times 9. but you let me do
it in my head since you have hints we
have hints you have hints that are
essentially doing that so we can use a
factor tree to break 18 to its prime
factorization it's 2 times 9. and 9 is
not it is odd but it is not prime it's
not prime it's not prime 2 doesn't go
into it so we're done with the 2. but 3
does 3 does three does so let's do that
oh so we see there three times three
leaving us with three three is prime so
we're done factoring that's right so
this is interesting we have a two and
then we are multiplying by three twice
right so it's going to be
two we have a two and we're going to
multiply by 3 twice
and 3 times 3 is 9.
and so 2 times 9 is 18. and that's what
we're looking for yeah
we we have not been able to prove the
fundamental theorem of arithmetic wrong
that's right
we haven't just printed it very very
very good well this is this is very neat